est ce que vous pensez refuser le
dialogue grégory et jean baptisé baril
est ce que vous pensez pas aussi alors
je donne pas de circonstances
atténuantes quoi que ce soit à à ce
policier est ce que vous pensez aussi c
est ce à cause des cadences folles de de
tout ce qu'ils peuvent vivre la journée
du monde de moyens voilà c'est comme
disait raquette à l'heure ce que c'est
un problème aussi politique qui se cache
derrière même des agressions comme celle
d'à c'est ras-le-bol qui fait que
aujourd'hui comme ils peuvent pas se
tourner vers les autorités et voilà il
parfois il peut être pas clos non enfin
je pense que je pense que globalement de
toute façon le métier de plus en plus
difficile c'est ça il ya une forte
pression une charge émotionnelle qui est
énorme
une baisse d'effectifs qui a été qualité
juste hallucinante par rapport à des
politiques qui sont enchaînés on a perdu
treize mille policiers en disant on
n'arrivera pas à à se remettre au niveau
même s'il ya une volonté politique où on
a cassé la machine de formation enfin
bref il ya tout ça qui vient qui vient
qui vient s'ajouter à des conditions de
travail qui sont en rien qui se vent qui
sont juste déplorable et en effet ça
colore forcément les interventions ça
les rend plus difficiles et il ya un
indicateur moi que je trouve super
important quand on parle du sentiment de
montée des violences dans la société
on a juste doubler le nombre de
policiers blessés en service en disant
c'est aujourd'hui on a donc là 12200 je
crois de mémoire policiers blessés
l'année dernière ça existe hallucinant
c'est de toi c'est 30 ya moi il faut
laisser baissier pour les jours il ya
moins le respect de l'uniforme qu'elle
en a plus y'a plus de respect du niqab
n'est quasiment plus la dirco du respect
avant il y avait la peur du gendarme
parce qu'on était on été élevé comme ça
il y avait cette appréhension là et la
peur et attention je fais pas de c'est
pas demain on compense la peur des fois
ça ça conditionne entre guillemets la
peur s'est formé nationaux mais gens
respectaient l'uniforme l'ordre etc
aujourd'hui regardez c'est pareil à un
élément qui est factuel le nombre de
refus d'obtempérer
aujourd'hui les flics on les écrase
comme des clébards et ça arrive
malheureusement tout de commandes
justement est très sombre